don't you love a good nap
just still in a way that small block of
time to curl up on your couch for that
sweet moment of escape it's one of my
favorite things but something I took for
granted before I began experiencing
homelessness as a teenager the ability
to take a nap is only reserved for
stability
ensuring is something you can't find
when you're carrying everything you own
in your bookbag and carefully counting
the amount of time you're allowed to sit
in any given place before being asked to
leave I grew up in Atlanta Georgia
bouncing from house to house with the
loving close-knit family as we struggled
to find stability in our finances but
when my mom temporarily lost herself to
mania and when that mania chose me as
his primary scapegoat through both
emotional and physical abuse I fled for
my safety I had come to the conclusion
that homelessness was safer for me than
being at home I was 16
during my homelessness I joined
Atlanta's 3,300 homeless youth and
filling uncared-for left out in a
visible each night that wasn't instilled
it's not any place for a homeless miner
to walk off the street to access a bed I
realized that most people thought of
homelessness as some kind of lazy
drug-induced squalor and inconvenience
but that didn't represent my book bag
full of clothes and schoolbooks on my a
plus grade point average I would sit on
my favorite bench downtown and watch as
the hours pass by until I can sneak in a
few hours to sleep on couches in cars
and buildings or in storage units I like
thousands of other homeless youth
disappeared into the shadows of the city
while the whole world kept spending I
have nothing at all had gone terribly
wrong the invisibility alone almost
completely broke my spirit but when I
had nothing else I had the Arts
something that didn't demand material
well from me in exchange for refuge a
few hours of singing writing poetry I
saving up enough money to disappear into
another world at a play kept me going
and jolting me back to life when I felt
at my lowest I would go to church
services on Wednesday evenings and
desperate for the relief the arts gave
me I will go a few hours early slip
downstairs and then to a part of the
world where the only thing that mattered
was whether or not I can hit the right
note in the song I was perfecting that
week I was seeing for hours it gave me
so much strength to give myself
permission to just block it all out and
sing five years later I started my
organization chop art which is a
multidisciplinary arts organization for
homeless miners chop our uses the arts
as a tool for trauma recovery by taking
what we know about building community
and restoring dignity and applying that
to the creative process chop artists
headquarter in Atlanta Georgia with
additional programs in Hyderabad India
in Accra Ghana and since I start in 2010
we've served over 40,000 teams worldwide
our teens take refuge in the
transformative elements of the arts and
they depend on the safe space char part
provides for them to do that and often
invisible population uses the arts to
step into their light but that journey
out of invisibility is not an easy one
we have a sibling pair Jeremy and Kelly
who's been with our program for over
three years they come to the chop art
classes every Wednesday evening but
about a year ago Jeremy and Kelly
witnessed their mom's season died right
in front of them they watched as the
paramedics failed to revive her they
cried as their father signed over
temporary custody to the chop art mentor
Aaron without even allowing them to take
prepare clothes on their way out this
series of events broke my heart
but Jeremy and Kelly's faith in
resolving shopper is what keeps me
grounded in this work Kelly :
Erin in her lowest moment knowing that
Erin would do whatever she could to make
them feel loved and cared for it's proof
to me that by using the arts as an entry
point we can heal and build our homeless
youth population and we continue to
build we built with Evan who became
homeless with his family when his mom
had to choose between medical bills or
the rent he discovered his love of
painting through chopped art we built
with Liz who's been on the streets most
of our teenage years but turns to music
to return to herself when her traumas
feel too heavy for her young shoulders
we built for Maria who uses poetry to
heal after her grandfather died in the
van she's living in with the rest of her
family and so to the youth out there
experiencing homelessness let me tell
you you have the power to build within
you you have a voice through the arts
that doesn't judge what you've been
through so never stop fighting to stand
in your light because even in your
darkest times we see you thank you
[Applause]